excusez moi avec vous cherchez les
sparrings pour mbarek et robuste
justement cette expérience vous cherchez
quoi comme sparring sa chance pareille
qui encaisse et qui fait pas chier basse
et moi ça
[Musique]
j'ai un contrat avec un groupe auxerre
oui j'ai en train d un team qui
s'appelle le tac mbarek qu'elle entraîne
tu vas faire son sparring quel ques
paris paris - chérie c'est quand un
champion comme tarek engage des boxeurs
comme ton père pour leur péter la gueule
pendant un mois tu vois bien comme je
reviens je suis pas les restos du coeur
mais j'ai un championnat d'europe pour
préparer je vais pas le temps d etat
l'impôt que j'ai des gens au top avec
nous par contre j'ai un truc que tu as
pas j'ai pris les chaos je suis retourné
sur le ring mais crois moi si tu l'as
pas digéré on se demandera jamais
champion que tu as été une surprise pour
toi ça te direct donc c'est samedi soir
en lever de rideau si ça convient de
combattre mais toujours dit que ton
frère pape et saint quentin 50 tu
t'arrêtes m'héberge terme il est
ce que c'est que ça tu te vois tu
quelqu'un t'a vu boxer quoi quand les
gens te regardent ils sont contentes
thermale on s'en foutra ne m'en fous pas
alors fais pas pour ce vide aurait voulu
être et moi voir celui qui aurait pu
être quelqu'un avec qui l'on doit
daniel
[Musique]